Cô cú phòng ngà trên bố lực lượng nước này đã ác sát tình đi đi vô,
cô vực chung tâm sẽ lược của quay nà,
lấy dấu bước tiền quan trọng trong việc mở dọng kẹn só át lặng tổ của quay nà.
Theo các bạn được, của một mở thân u quay nà,
nà đã chếm hơn một chung chỉ mới kỳ là mất vông tình xú mì chỉ trong cho đề một tháng,
và hiện các đơn vị thuật xưa đoàn sẽ tăng số chỉ mới của ngà,
đã vượt dành dời kia tầy của đô nhé,
tiến vào cú vực dát lành dời với đi đi vô,
nơi từ có hơn 8 chữ dần trước chiến sức.
Chuyên kẹp hiện chưa phản hồi chính tức trên bố cùng ngà,
sự việc cho thời giao chán kịt duyến vẫn rất càng thằng trong khi quan trực 2 nước đàn 1 bàn đào phản hòa bình.
Ngà vẫn là bên đào dành dành dữ thế hơn trong phung đô khi kiểm soát gần
với chính phân trong bản thủ quay nà.
Trong khi quay nà, gần tới dầy mạnh các nòn tình công bằng ua vê và phản hoại vào hạn tầng của sự ngà,
bao gồm có mở bây nay bông chính đưa bảo chuyện được sát.
Ngà đắt trả bằng việc tập kích thành phố kia kích bằng ua vê tên lừa và bông dẫn đường.
Khiến ý nhất bố người chế hưởng sống ở bây giờ trong đêm 1 tạm sấu,
ngà cú tên bố bàn hạc, sống ở bố bảo vệ ua vê ua quay nà, gần mắt cơ vah,
bộ hải sân bay lần tại tụi đô phải tạm thời đồng cửa.
Cú bình quan tự hai nước, ngà cậm thằng sau, ngà bố quay nà bông phát chánh gã vê việc chào chả thị thế bí xí từ chân.
Khiều thảo thuật đà đường tại Istan đồn của đô tháng.
Ngà cậu bố quay nà chỉ hoảng tự cho đối và bán rao hơn mấy hàng ít dây trong khi kiét mắt bỏ và yêu cầu mắt cơ vah đối thoại từ chân hơn.